Mike Cernovich, how are you?
- Nice to meet you finally.
- Nice to meet you too.
Thanks for coming in.
- I think I actually trolled
your show.
- I'm sure you did.
- You and the--
I forget the rapper's name--did
a "Problematic," like,
rap or something on cultural
appropriation.
- Did I trigger you?
- You definitely didn't.
- No?
- I thought it was kind of
funny.
- You thought that the video was
funny or trolling me was funny?
- Both
- Oh, yeah?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Success.
So what is a cuck?
- I use it just to mean beta,
weak.
I use it very--I wouldn't
consider you a cuck.
- Really? Why not?
- No.
I would call you beta.
I would say you're beta male.
- So I'm not all the way at
cuck.
- Beta's just a non-aggressive,
maybe a little bit passive of a
man.
- Yeah, and with this kind of
hairstyle.
You get more respect for a cuck
or a beta than a normie?
Like, at least that's something?
- No, normie's great.
Normie's just, like, they don't
get it.
For example, I don't do satire
anymore.
Why not?
Well, Normie's aren't gonna get
satire.
- You were so good at it.
- Well, it's a little--
five years later, it doesn't age
well.
- Do you hate the Left?
- Definitely not.
That's why we're having a
conversation.
I usually say no.
I say--I've turned down "The
Daily Show."
I've turned down everybody.
- Oh, and I appreciate you being
here.
- I always say no to TV,
because all you people want
to do is edit things out of
context.
- I give you my word we would
never edit you out of context
like that; that's not the kind
of show we do here.
What's--what's the most cuck
thing you've ever done?
- I had sex with Bill Clinton
with a strap-on.
- Eww.
- Oh, yeah, skeet skeet.
- All right
What do you hope to accomplish
long-term?
- I like the idea of sucking
Hitler's penis.
It's on the to-do list for sure.
- Good. Okay.
Do people hate you?
- I deserve a lot of the hate
that I get.
There are things that I've said
or done.
I've been mean to people
gratuitously.
You know, I wish I hadn't done
that.
So when people are mean to me, I
just view that as karma.
- Yeah. What's the soundtrack of
the alt-right?
- 'Cause I like house music.
[upbeat house music]
We love it.
A lot of people ask me all the
time--people ask me
what--think--about Hillary?
She's beautiful, intelligent...
house music.
Trolled your show--
trolled your show.
Hegelian dialectic.
Trolled your show.
♪ ♪
Oh--oh, yeah.
- I love trolls.
- Hegelian dialectic.
Oh, oh, yeah.
[laughs]
- Thanks for coming in, Mike.
I appreciate it, man.
Thanks for coming in.